and Yaya is the organizer of this
project planting a special kind of grass
and eucalyptus saplings which help
desalinate the soil she also brought
together the women who were implementing
the project and got the local foresters
involved it's not been possible to grow
crops here for two decades the soil is
just too salty when I was a child we
grew our own rice here in Jaffa doot I
never had to buy any the same with
peanuts and millet the problem is the
rising sea level saltwater is invading
and destroying more and more fertile
land this dike was built five years ago
and provides some relief loose mining
works for an environmental NGO he
advises the women and helped them get
funds from the un-backed Green Climate
Fund he also helps farmers here the
vegetable growers also want to benefit
from the fund what can it do for them
they need to acquire new skills you've
helped us so far but you must leave us
alone now there is more to do the money
for this project did not come from
Senegal but from an international fund
the soil the women are working on is
still salty but they want to find out
whether they can already resume farming
here they've planted a small patch of
rice as an experiment they'll know in
about two months if the soil is
recovering and will yield a crop
a tanker truck suddenly appears the
driver has evidently just dumped a load
of human waste llaman da is really angry
blah blah its destructive it disrupts
the ecological balance it's toxic
the truck doesn't have a number plate
and the driver wants to hide his face
the forester Mamadou Sonia is also a
lieutenant in the army he takes the
driver's ID and driver's license and
escorts the truck to the police station
llaman diego's to see the mayor Mamadou
Sonia also shows up then llaman dia
pitches her ideas we were able to build
the dike with money from a fund dubrow G
now we want local authorities to help us
make use of the dike now it's there
young people involved many youngsters
have already helped women plant trees I
applied to have water pipes lead to the
plots of the young vegetable farmers and
as far as the dice so that we could have
enough water there that would help
disseminate the soil even more but they
rejected my application so Yama and Dia
won't get any more help here in fact the
mayor says he has no more money to spend
and asks us man yang how he might get
some from the Green Climate Fund
the rising sea level is also having an
impact on Joelle floods busy fishing
port thousands of people come here every
day to trade and process the catch
mainly sardines
if the water carried away the beach the
local economy would collapse a
breakwater was built a few years ago to
slow erosion but it's in poor condition
and is in urgent need of repair the fish
smokers were too small to start with and
now they're broken with no help
available from domestic sources all eyes
are on international bodies in order to
launch a project you have to know how to
do it you have to know what the
requirements of the fund are what kinds
of projects it backs so there's a whole
set of elements you have to understand
and then the project has to get through
several rounds of evaluation please
Ilkley despite all the difficulties the
women have already achieved a lot
nothing's been grown here for a long
time is the ground dry and hard yes
there's lots of clay in the soil will
melons grow here
we'll see if they grow or not a year ago
the local authority gave llaman di is
women's cooperative the land they've
been working on it had been waste ground
the 40 women share the 4 hectare plot
after the rainy season the donors are
going to drill a well and teach the
women how to grow vegetables then
they'll really get to work women in
Senegal are at a great disadvantage
because only men inherit land it's an
exceptional opportunity for this women's
collective to earn their own money here
in the evening they head to the coast
where they planted mangroves two years
ago this too is a project for which Yama
and Dia got support from the Climate
Fund the women cut and plant shoots from
their burgeoning mangroves it's hard
work but this reforest ation project is
bearing fruit strong winds have
destroyed many homes but nothing
happened around here we think that has
to do with the local ecosystem with the
reforestation project and all the
mangroves we have here now migratory
birds stop by again and shellfish have
come back llaman dia is now thinking
about farming oysters among the
mangroves that would combine
environmental protection with female
empowerment and what could prove to be a
profitable business